you dare enter this house
[ __ ] do you think you're dealing huncle
Joe is here with his hoop to fiddle
merengue had to throw it [ __ ] he that
you [ __ ] like Roger Clemens in 88
87 I have no [ __ ] idea was too busy
[ __ ] eatin ass and snapping
[ __ ] how are you this evening
I was just Sydney and thinking to myself
I went to the store got some new leads
today you know they wanna share with my
[ __ ] church family we got this
[ __ ] sonic boom cents a star from
perennial off tremendous indica [ __ ]
home of the blind forget about and then
over here I got some sour gia I bread
with an indica [ __ ] Dominus
but Joey what's with the jitter Jen
let's smoke these [ __ ] and see
the effects
who's the telling the suck nothing
I was over here for a few minutes get my
head together I said you know what why
not happen for the family see what the
[ __ ] they're up to
it's after dinner you know bang doing
not necess it now I [ __ ] bought these
your mouth will hang out smoke a bowl
uncle Joey and that's a call tonight I'm
headed I'm gonna relax I got it right
from notes down I got a nine o'clock
show the Black Horse is so wound up
there leave yeah just be there when man
James
it's a [ __ ] savagery understanding
man Lightman's up there we got a bunch
it was going up there you got muscles
with [ __ ] chorizo they out of my
salad come on Thomas and that's it had a
nice day today I've moved some stuff
over to the house this weed looks good
this [ __ ] sensei this [ __ ] looks
pretty serious and picking up on the way
back was on a mission this afternoon
picking up is 96 degrees and put it the
[ __ ] bag and again I'm gonna dry out
the Sun to the kiss of us forbidden it
becomes like a dances that's when I
should [ __ ] bubble
who the [ __ ] do you think you're dealing
with do you think I would bother you
right now at dinnertime if I wasn't
flowing here is that the type of mother
[ __ ] do you think I am you think I would
show up Mike get up I'm showing up with
two [ __ ] bazookas with this wave yet
it pays to smoke the best
nice tastes good doesn't burn I feel it
going into the [ __ ] carpal tunnels of
my brain understand that feeling right
now it's down to blank nuts
that's not [ __ ] and briefly actually
feel more heat inside man stops what the
fuchsias bleep that bad sense a star not
a nice little [ __ ] in the Kamiya list
nah man in the compact [ __ ] had
not my mr. teeth at 8 o'clock at night
I'm just blowing smoke for three hours
damaging my lungs more than their big
damage if you have a strong sturdy bump
off that [ __ ] 6:00 a.m. and I'm
forget about it I'll start jumping up
and down like a [ __ ] marine but even
at night after we let go and he then
gonna do about the man tell people all
the time I'll smoke weed at night I saw
him now with you [ __ ] savages because
[ __ ] that I wanted to see but you've got
such as well because I love that's right
yeah this is this ship that st. Paul's
is ready let's try out this batch here
and put the lid back on this you got to
be very controlled I'm not a [ __ ]
thing an earthquake my your weeds on the
floor find out you know I need that [ __ ]
my life oh yeah this is some
[ __ ] some nice blue your diesel
sow or that type of [ __ ] that should
always put me a different planet from a
certain store though a lot of people try
to push appeal my sound with these from
the girls city but it ain't it I could
top I look like that no these are
[ __ ] and why city myself you
can't [ __ ] the [ __ ] [ __ ] hell
no
16:50 no.66 six weeks away from shooting
my special guys I got about 35 minute
and plus I gotta come and put another 20
in next material but I'm trying to give
you [ __ ] you know I can't give
you them carrot because the special
comes out next week they'll be sitting
there going Joey I've heard this 82
times before some tryna work should have
few cops eyes that's why never look beep
into the murky waters of the underworld
by the way this [ __ ] indica yep
that sensei star yep stuck mum I'm
hearing Barbra Streisand and now I know
I've always loved you but my heart
belongs to me I'm sorry about that I get
all emotional Barbra Streisand that's my
badge is shaking I'm saying what do you
want tell you everything if you want to
run with the Jews that run with Barbra
Streisand if you're not listening to
Barbra Streisand go shoot yourself right
now that's how that happened that we do
the Jew isn't right there and we're not
with them
first thing get a little promise try
sometimes you never think you save you
gotta bug somebody whatever the [ __ ]
they are pulling your wedding band from
give a [ __ ] and you have a sip in the
heavy duty area with the other Jews put
a tuxedo on just not from time to time
what up what up there Irving you know
I'm saying it's probably some the Barbra
Streisand I can't give you all the
advice in the world the best advice I've
given you see Barbra Streisand is [ __ ]
top 10 last out last 10 hours you were
[ __ ] call don't even listen to Barbra
Streisand they just give a hundred our
bill sales line yeah is my god stigma
that's how it works you imagine being
that strong of a Jew people just giving
you yards
let's try out this [ __ ] style hit
oh yeah
this is strong refill history for that
since our butts in their [ __ ] geeks
and then their [ __ ] bags this [ __ ]
I had a stand before I should have that
hold you understand me well you guys
don't need me at dinner the other night
[ __ ] in the salad boy Lannister
laughing a nice little piece of fish
what the [ __ ] did you do you probably
ate two cheeseburgers for a dollar and
you're waiting for you [ __ ] - it's
blood can't eat that [ __ ] not one time
for you [ __ ] throw some heat who's
that over there I'm always watching you
never know a nicest neighborhood dressed
up with your ice cream man I'm sayin
nice I can't even stuff to tell you how
I am moving my eyeballs let's it mess
them mighty and that came on here
specifically to smoke the ball with you
[ __ ] does that's what normal
people do normal people don't go to
[ __ ] happen do you think you can give
a [ __ ] you smoke a bowl you ask yourself
what's in your heart that's what it's
all about and that's it let's finish
this
moving out in two days limitation
the wood is wreath in a [ __ ] reason
we cannot [ __ ] be for you when they
knock this down someone's going to come
out of it will they note I might see
that that instead but anyway I love
little pick a show moving right you know
you know my [ __ ] baby my [ __ ]
around I think it's a little better
[ __ ] then it's like Jonathan tall and
all that [ __ ] [ __ ] who gives a [ __ ]
everybody's got across the bed
live your [ __ ] life [ __ ] em off say
advice and you guys tell them all to
suck your dick
Wednesday is another day and you're
gonna be a lot better than them plus
you're gonna be smokin all right kind of
suckers don't forget about me tomorrow
Church 3 p.m. in the afternoon that's
how we're gonna keep on 3 Peter being
[ __ ] around
see to have it my friends tonight you
can take it on your trip get hip on your
barbecue show you frenzy [ __ ] kind of
sucks I love you right tell them or
sniff your [ __ ] nut sack won't go
away easy into the night